Mày ai mới thân năm tại Mắc Cánh, tổng thống nèa là đi milk chiên và chụt thích chú của tổ cận bình đã tiến hành hộ đam sông phương,
tập chung và quan hệ đối thách chỉ lực toàn diện giải nước.
Pháp biểu lấy khai mặt, tổng thống thu chiến nhìn mạnh, quan hệ nèi ngà và chung đang ở mất cao trước tổng cáo,
đồng thời sử dụng thành lưỡ chung của một ngày hôm gặp tự bà thung để thị dẫn mức độ cạnh kết.
Hạng tiền Rồi Tân Sva Truyên thông nha nữa chú của tổng thống thu chiến đã ở chủ tịch tập cận bình là người bạn thân mấy nước và thậm đệng
hài bên suy chi lế là thu xoên.
Bây giờ mình, chủ tịch tập cận bình nhấn mạnh, bất độ tín cải chính trị ngày càng dấu xác giãi bên,
đồng thời đề cập tựa tái trường thương mạnh, năng lượng khoa công nghệ và xa lương nhân dân.
Hài bên thống nhất thu tụt đại hợp tăng ngược, chung đó ngà suy chi và chọn nhà cục cấp lưỡn,
còn chung quốc là đủ tắc thử thu của quan trọng.
Khi này thương mạnh sông phương tí tụt tăng trường mạnh, đưa thay trong tí đủ là Mỹ trong những hăng cạnh đây.
Bây các tấn đệ của tế, 2 nhà lãnh đạo bài to quan điểm chung để về cân sớm chấm giúp xung đồ tại trường đông,
và đà mồn định trối cuối ngứng và thương mạnh thần cầu.
Tầm thống thu chiến nhấn mạnh hợp tăng ngà chung, là yếu tổ ổn định quan trọng, cho bất cảnh trở tự thử dời tụt có những chuyển dịch theo hướng đà cụ.